between flood lines and technical
difficulties fans have gotten to see the
cast of Breaking bad's true colors and a
surprising amount of sexuality through
the show's official blooper reels
Breaking Bad fans will never forget the
Fallout from Hank's fateful trip to the
bathroom where he finally realizes
Heisenberg's true identity when the
second part of season 5 debuted Hank
played by Dean Norris wastes no time
confronting Walt about his double life
while this tense standoff between Hank
and Waltz is Unforgettable you might not
know that to get this Uber serious
moment right the Breaking Bad crew had
to overcome some pretty hilarious
technical issues in the bloopers for the
second half of season five we see the
attempts at this scene gone wrong at the
moment when Hank pushes the button to
threateningly close the garage door it
repeatedly gets stuck Norris keeps
jamming the button to try and get the
door shut but to no avail at one point
Norris gives up and drops a garage door
remote on the table to end a take before
dramatically falling over unfortunately
by that point neither actors seemed to
be able to keep it together to get
through a take without cracking up this
blooper is a Brian Cranston classic and
one of the rare hilarious moments that
came from the actor staying in character
rather than breaking it in this season 4
outtake the filmmakers were trying to
capture a low angle shot of Walt
sticking a bill into a vending machine
it's a small shot you probably don't
remember but when Cranston can't quite
seem to get the machine to take the
Dollar on Unforgettable moment erupts in
the take Krantz then feeds the bill into
the machine multiple times only for it
to be spat back out of the actor after
the machine repeatedly rejects him
Cranston still in character mutters a
certain name under his breath but the
man he's referring to is the original
owner of the car wash since Walt and
bogdon have never had a particularly
friendly relationship it's no surprise
that Walt would blame ball gone for not
keeping his vending machines in working
order in a characteristically
manipulative moment from season two all
types Jesse up by liking him to a
blowfish in his defense it's an apt
metaphor as Walter says both Jesse and
the Blowfish start out unassuming small
and stature not Swift not cunning
easy prey for Predators the point of
this comparison was to highlight Jesse's
ability to intimidate others when he
needs to even if he appears weak on the
outside the speech works and Jesse is
noticeably more energized for the rest
of the scene however in the Breaking Bad
season 2 bloopers we see what happens
when Brian Cranston can't quite nail the
line the final line of the speech is the
rhetorical question who messes with the
Blowfish Jesse in the outtakes Cranston
slips up by repeatedly calling Jesse the
wrong name who messes with the Blowfish
Jeff
if you're wondering who Jeff could
possibly be even Cranston himself
doesn't know as the Bloomer continues we
see him rack his brain to try and figure
out just where that came from we may
never know the answer but we are
thankful for this famous blood
regardless
this behind the scenes moment shows us
the light side of Breaking Bad star and
a gun while Skyler white was pretty much
all business all the time during gun
scenes on the drama it's clear from this
season 2 blooper that the actress who
played her has a much better sense of
humor in this series of Clips we see
gone on set holding a prosthetic hand
and she feels herself up with a hand the
actor is jokingly moans tuko's name
before throwing her head back and
cackling at the absurdity of what she's
doing
Brian Cranston and Aaron Paul got very
close throughout the shooting of
breaking back so close in fact that
their friendship has extended well into
the decades since the series last season
aired Paul and cranston's chemistry both
on and off screen was so natural that
Jesse's original fate was even written
out of the show to keep him on his main
character however if you haven't seen
this particular outtake you might not
realize just how close the two were or
as close as the two were emotionally
some viewers might be surprised how
close they'd gotten physically in this
Breaking Bad season 2 blooper the actors
who play Walt and Jesse have an intimate
moment of male bonding in this clip the
two are embracing when Paul reaches for
cranston's butt and starts to rub his
co-star the actors start to verbally
flirt with one another while trying to
strip off their Hazard suits essential
moment might change the way you look at
Walt and Jesse's relationship the next
time you re-watch Breaking Bad when most
viewers think of Breaking Bad they think
of one iconically menacing line spoken
by Walter White in season four I am not
in danger Skyler I am the danger as
legendary as the scene is Cranston and
Gunn didn't get it on every tank
thankfully they showrunners included
some of the mishaps from the scene in
the season 4 blooper reel in this clip
gun tease Cranston up perfectly
delivering her line about Walt being in
danger with absolute sincerity the
response starts as a smile but before
Cranston can break into the main part of
his speech he starts laughing
uncontrollably something about the
moment was just too much for Cranston we
all laugh in uncomfortable situations
but there's something particularly
bizarre about seeing Walter White break
in that moment in one of the most
outlandish moments of his entire career
Brian Cranston let it all lose while
filming a shower scene for Breaking Bad
season 4. in addition to being
completely naked and in the middle of
shaving his head this blooper depicts
the disrobed Cranston singing a
SpongeBob SquarePants theme song parody
while waiting for the showrunners to get
the right shot Cranston chooses to adopt
a pirate accent before singing to
himself
horse naked with a light meter the
answer is not entirely clear although
you can definitely make out that whoever
this Shanty is about is known for their
quote sweaty balls as he continues he
backs up into the frame where if not for
the mercy of the editors viewers would
have become even more intimately
familiar with cranston's body than the
pilot episode allows we've already seen
how in the face of technical
difficulties Brian Cranston can
improvise silly contributions to scenes
that still make some sense in the
context of the show however his
interaction with Gus spring actor
Giancarlo Esposito is anything but
sensible in this outtake from Breaking
Bad season 4 Bryan Cranston improvises
between tanks by ordering a meal at the
register while Esposito takes his order
while a tense conversation should be
transpiring in these moments Cranston
just keeps telling Esposito his order in
the end Cranston tells him in a top-tier
deadpan about his dietary restrictions
and I know I'm allergic to Tacos in the
lab where they cook math Walt and Jesse
are often seen transporting large
plastic boxes and barrels filled with
various chemicals occasionally these
barrels have been filled with bodies
dissolving an acid having disposed of a
body by doing the same thing early in
season one it seems the pair have just
gotten used to this morbid occupational
hazard this aspect of their job adds a
stark contrast to the season 4 blooper
or Cranston and Paul are seeing playing
with an empty one of these barrels the
clip begins with Cranston holding a
large plastic barrel by the lid and
slamming it onto the floor in an attempt
to open the top Paul comes in and starts
pounding on it and Cranston gives it a
large kick it's not the most outstanding
of the season for bloopers but it does
provide a unique look behind the show's
curtain this blooper comes off like
Brian Cranston doing a comedy sketch in
the same vein as his shower song we
weren't quite sure what the actor was on
that day but we appreciate his
improvisational Antics even more this
time around in this clip from the third
season 4 blooper wheel Cranston delivers
a satire of a PSA directly to the camera
what is it for anal bleaching as it
turns out from the cast of The Crew an
anal bleaching kit
because now crew should walk around with
a dark anus Fulton Skyler's marital life
has always been complicated to say the
least between the constant power
struggle the lies and the cheating it's
far from a typical married relationship
even so some elements of their romantic
life remained a mystery to the audience
throughout the run of the series at
least until the season 4 blooper reels
came out in this outtake from season 4
Brian Krantz then walks up to Anna Gunn
while clothed in a baby costume diaper
and all before taking a pacifier out of
his mouth to speak I know it was my
fantasy but I hope you got some
enjoyment gun laughs and cheekily calls
Cranston a good boy before giving her
co-star a playful spank in the final
season the Breaking Bad audiences saw
the long-awaited return of some
characters that had been out of focus
for several seasons in one scene we see
Jesse's old friends Badger and skinny
Pete up to their old nonsense while
running an errand for Jesse and Walt
this time we see them messing around
with the instruments in a music store as
Badger played by Matt Jones hammers away
on the guitar to no avail we see Pete
played by Charles Baker turn out a nice
classical Melody on piano all these
events might already sound familiar to
those who have seen the show this season
behind blooper shows a longer clip
featuring an extended piano solo by
skinny Pete Baker continues his
classical demonstration long after Jones
stopped strumming in the take ends as he
plays Jones looks on in frustration
until Baker finishes his moment
yeah we get it you're better
foreign
[Music]